okay it's a white go thumbnail shot here
we go ah oh my god no number thumb is
shot holy cow it's a me hi everyone this
is Nina today I'm getting my stuff
pepper stuffed pepper is super yummy and
that's easy to make and everybody likes
it and I like it too the ingredient that
you will need for stuffed pepper is one
onion I'm going to use to pep green
peppers and then to red to yellow one
off i won arms because the other orange
is actually not good celery sticks
mushrooms oh and garlic you will meet
ground beef stir crampy and I use quinoa
and filled the rice soaked in with its
so much happier to compare to the white
rice so I'm gonna use white quinoa okay
so let's start I'm just gonna chop up
some random first four cloves of garlics
I always crush the the garnet because
it's easier to shop in
maybe next time could get ever to
prepare all the ingredients and I just
cook so thanks the onions I'm crying ok
so don't think and we use five celery
sticks the correct way to clean the
mushrooms use the web paper towel boy
the mushrooms but I'm not going to do
them just gonna raise it up I feel you
cut the peppers but I'm gonna start
cooking right now it has a
onions caramelize so I'm going to throw
in the past and let them cook so 3
tablespoon of canola oil or you could
use any or you you prefer so far for
some pepper after it's done after stuff
i will sprinkle with cheese and then
bake it for like two minutes or so so i
have to set the oven for 425 fahrenheit
kick so it's ready when I throw in the
onion and garlic
oh it smells good while waiting for
district folk I'm going to go back to
cut the peppers so how you cut the
pepper you have to be careful i just won
the middle part 2 because i just want to
be the quad-city [ __ ] pick out the M
that's the piece doesn't have to be
just pull it up make sure you come back
yes sir
if you see the mushroom their little
brown now you can have a seller
maybe you should name each of the
peppers yeah like that's bill I think
you should try to juggle ok let's try ok
so suddenly I feel far I don't know I
can't right
okay so this is ready I should up the
the peace now this is 1.8 kg organic see
from gospel it's individually type
number three packs so I'm just going to
use one we're going to add one more
tablespoon of oil physically it's like a
stir fries just make sure everything is
all mixed up together start by it
doesn't have to be in this order if you
have seen Evans Valentine's Day cook
stir-fry cooking you will know just put
everything in together that's not as
everything gets cook it's fun there's no
order now I'm going to add my this I
made this team my last night i use my
rice cooker this is 2 cup of quinoa
okay so it's all mix well i'm gonna add
some salt some pepper
to pinch of oregano
about 2 tbsp up with castor sauce
tac cup of oil stuff
trim up the heat and just mix well and
you ready I'm ready to transfer the
transfer this to thee to the peppers so
get a baking pan that look of discuss
was nina thought the pen was dirty
ashley
very colorful plate get a spoon so that
you can stuff the stuff inside stuff the
stuff inside this is more than enough
for seven peppers no you want to see us
on sing sing a song sing it loudly sing
it I don't know I picked the wrong song
maybe nikka should sing a song oh I am
saying you know me Monsieur when you
stop the peppers don't get it up all the
way because we still want to ask some
add some cheese on the top so maybe like
this you can still see the rim
hey
so this is much chatted mozzarella
cheese you can get any shredded cheese
so sprinkle they do it Jesus Christ why
do you have me
now the oven is hot going to put it in
the oven let it bake for 5 minutes just
get the cheese to melt
you can make the sub pepper longer if
you want to get that the softness the
bell when you bite into the pepper but
Evan and I we like the crunchiness of
the pepper so we'll need we've only
taken 45 minutes or so maybe less while
we wait why don't we show them Evans
weekend project outside this is my
weekend project I have to dig what am I
digging digging and digging out the
grass to allow Nina to plant inside her
greenhouse we move the greenhouse and
that big pile of dirt is almost done I
need to finish digging so you can plant
all of your plants in the ground instead
of using all of those parts so that is
my weekend project alright we're back
what's Nina doing I'm trying to put the
seed in the bay so it's safe and to try
to kind of see what happened save the
green ones wasn't the best 20 who could
do it faster where's my bag yeah
hey maybe you started reporting no I did
this after you okay what do you do this
you see how this ha ha ha ha ha Satan
look at my seat of everyone here we go
up a seat around here shut up Oh hold on
so it's about five minutes after we're
gonna take the green peppers now I see
what happens oh ha oh honey whoa here it
is stuffed pepper with cheese now we can
I come on up and try it inside
it's like my era
Oh
I'm about to say something important but
before I do that let me take a humongous
quite a friend thanks for watching the
video I hope you enjoyed this dish
please like and comment below and let me
know what you want you to make next I
believe you gotta throw this and you
might catch in my mouth get ready hold
on come on shirt side all right let me
come down to your height okay one two
three sauces or upgrade okay 1230 I you
see can you pick up it picking up sticks
Randall each it good boy [ __ ] you think
back to queens are all of my work
hey chicken